[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday December
6th and as you can see despite all of
the vicious teasing and comments I'm
still wearing my nerd glasses the top
three nerd glasses joke so far number
three did you get those from the British
National Health Service number two I'm
not gonna make a joke because I assume
the glasses themselves are a joke and
number one you look exactly like uncle
junior from The Sopranos Hank I think
that in a lot of ways peer pressure is
healthy and good
like for instance Hank say that I'm five
years old and I know a two-year-old this
two-year-old could be my brother he
could be a friend whatever I'm not going
to name any names but he's probably my
brother now let's say that this
two-year-old has just learned how to
tinkle on his own and he's really
excited about it I don't blame him Hank
being able to tinkle on your own is
exciting but Hank maybe this
two-year-old is so excited about being
able to tinkle on his own that he
sometimes takes out the equipment before
going to the bathroom and then sort of
waddles into the bathroom while everyone
laughs and then maybe later
five-year-old me points out to the
two-year-old nameless person that you
can't take the equipment out until
you're inside the bathroom with the door
closed now in that purely hypothetical
example Hank the two-year-old has
learned an important lesson
usually the social order is the way it
is for a reason but then sometimes the
social order thinks things that are
absolutely freaking mad like for
instance that you should cover your
front lawn with plants that don't
produce edible fruit and require a lot
of water to maintain or that the kind of
glasses you wear are in some way
reflective of the kind of person you are
now Hank generally my response to the
social order not looking like I want it
to look like is just to complain but the
yetis response has always been to try to
do stuff which brings me to the green
green manifesto so Hank about three
months ago I was on the road somewhere
and I got a call from the Yeti saying
that she was writing a manifesto
well Hank naturally I got excited as you
know I'm a huge fan of manifestos
I think the manifesto is potentially the
most underutilized of all literary
genres it turns out that the yetis
manifesto was on the subject of our not
living in a way that's in line with our
values here in Indianapolis and in a
series of bullet points she outlined
some ways that we could live better
lives but what point number one compost
I'd show you the compost but it's frozen
shut anyway be grateful you don't have
smell-o-vision
but what point number two light bulbs
Hank for the last three months we have
only been buying those crazy whirligig
light bulbs because the crazy whirligig
light bulbs give off way more efficient
light plus their attorney
bullet point number two cloth bags ever
since we put the green green manifesto
into use we've just used cloth bags at
the grocery store instead of plastic
bags
not only do cloth bags create less waste
they're also just way better at carrying
groceries bullet point number three no
more soda
the thing about soda and bottled water
and stuff is that it's very expensive to
ship heavy things and a liquid is always
heavy there was a study recently that
showed that one single bottle of Fiji
water requires two pounds of carbon to
go from Fiji to the United States so
instead of drinking soda which is super
heavy and requires a lot of packaging
and shipping and stuff we're drinking
Crystal Light I would just drink the tap
water here but it tastes like poison
bullet point number four no more paper
in the kitchen Hank we drastically
reduced our use of paper towels by
always using cloth napkins and dishrags
bullet point number five it turns out
you can recycle all kinds of stuff you
didn't even know you could recycle Hank
before the green green manifesto we
produced about four kitchen bags full of
garbage each week now we produce less
than one bullet point I haven't been
keeping track of the numbers but I'm
going to guess that it's number six
buying local food
Hank one of the most unexpected things
to come out of the Green Green manifesto
is that I've learned I don't hate
Tomatoes I thought I hated Tomatoes ever
since I was a baby but it turns out I
just hate crappy Tomatoes I quite like
the tomatoes from the local farmers
market and finally Hank peer-pressure be
damned we're letting large swathes of
our property become native Indiana
grasses which don't require watering
because sometimes you have to listen to
the peer pressure of Olive society and
sometimes you just have to listen to the
peer pressure coming from your brother
and peer pressure wise you're a great
brother let me know if you have any
other tips and congratulations on eco
geeks three millionth visitor I'll see
you tomorrow
scavenger hunters today is a discussion
day not a clue day